hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 36 y hablaremos de la
ley de velocidad anteriormente ya hemos
hablado de las reacciones y de cómo su
velocidad puede cambiar por ejemplo esta
es la reacción de la descomposición del
amoniaco tenemos amoniaco que se separa
en hidrógeno y nitrógeno gaseoso y esta
es una reacción que ocurre a velocidad
constante es decir si tenemos una
concentración alta o baja de amoniaco la
cantidad que se consume es constante y
la velocidad no cambia pero si tenemos
dióxido de nitrógeno que se separa en
óxido nítrico y oxígeno tendremos algo
diferente miren cuando hay mucho dióxido
de nitrógeno
la reacción ocurre rápidamente pero
después ya no tanto ahora si solamente
observamos las ecuaciones químicas
balanceadas no hay forma de saber qué
tan rápido ocurren y eso es algo muy
importante que debemos de tomar en
cuenta cuando estudiamos la ley de
velocidad entonces la ley
de velocidad se refiere a la cantidad de
reactivos que se consumen en una
reacción así que no tenemos que
preocuparnos por los productos y esta es
la ecuación la velocidad de una reacción
es igual a k la constante de velocidad
por la concentración del reactivo en
este caso de a elevada a la potencia m y
esa potencia es la que nos dirá el orden
de la reacción nosotros hablaremos de
tres tipos de reacciones orden cero
primer orden y segundo orden y cómo se
verá una gráfica de orden ser bueno si
elevamos algo a la potencia cero será
igual a uno entonces si esto es igual a
uno nos queda que la velocidad es igual
acá la constante de velocidad pero si
analizamos una reacción de primer orden
entonces esto está elevado a la primera
potencia y por lo tanto la velocidad es
igual a la constante de velocidad por la
concentración de a y obtendremos esta
curva
observen que al principio la reacción
ocurre rápidamente pero después la
velocidad de reacción disminuye y bueno
finalmente si tenemos una reacción de
segundo orden la velocidad es igual acá
por la concentración de a al cuadrado y
podemos ver que entre más reactivo
tengamos la reacción será más rápida
y algo muy importante todo esto lo
tienen que determinar experimentalmente
no podemos simplemente observar una
ecuación química y saber cuál es la
velocidad de esa reacción y qué pasó si
tenemos más de un reactivo bueno la ley
de velocidad se sigue aplicando y nos
queda así velocidad es igual acá la
constante de velocidad por la
concentración de a elevada a la potencia
m por la concentración debe elevada a la
potencia n entonces cada uno de los
reactivos puede tener una reacción de
orden diferente y si queremos conocer el
orden total de la reacción
simplemente sumamos los valores entonces
les enseñaré cómo usar los datos para
saber cuál es el orden de una reacción
vamos a ver en una reacción de orden
cero este es el ejemplo que les di a al
principio la descomposición de amoniaco
en hidrógeno gaseoso y nitrógeno gaseoso
para este caso la velocidad es igual acá
así que no importa qué tanto amoniaco
tengamos la reacción ocurrirá a la misma
velocidad
ahora si analizamos los datos imaginen
que hicimos tres experimentos en los que
modificamos la concentración de a y
obtuvimos que la velocidad es siempre la
misma
entonces si al analizar los datos
obtenemos una velocidad constante
podemos decir que es una reacción de
orden cero y como podríamos saberlo si
sólo tuviéramos la gráfica bueno para
conocer la velocidad simplemente
necesitamos calcular la pendiente de la
recta si calcula en la pendiente aquí
aquí se darán cuenta de que es la misma
y si grafica mos la velocidad contra el
tiempo obtendremos una línea recta pero
ahora si tenemos una reacción de primer
orden
esta es la descomposición de peróxido de
hidrógeno ahora la velocidad es igual
acá por la concentración de a y así es
como se ve la gráfica y bueno suponiendo
que nuevamente hicimos tres experimentos
en los que modificamos la concentración
de a podemos ver que al duplicar la
concentración se duplica la velocidad
igual aquí al duplicar la concentración
se duplicó la velocidad y si ahora
calculamos las pendientes al principio
tenemos una pendiente pronunciada pero
al final no tanto y si grafica mos la
velocidad contra el tiempo obtenemos una
línea recta que va descendiendo con el
tiempo ahora otra forma de saber esto es
calculando el logaritmo natural de la
concentración y de esa forma también
obtendremos una línea recta como este lo
mejor de eso es que la pendiente de esa
y nos dirá cuál es el valor de la
constante de velocidad acá y finalmente
si analizamos una reacción de segundo
orden
sabemos que irá todavía más rápido y la
velocidad es igual acá por la
concentración al cuadrado entonces si
comparamos los experimentos en donde
teníamos una concentración de 0.1 y 0.2
parece que la velocidad se duplicó pero
no se dejen engañar en realidad se eleva
al cuadrado 2 al cuadrado es 4 y 4 al
cuadrado es 16 y si gráfica moss la
velocidad contra el tiempo obtenemos una
curva como este al principio la
pendiente nos indica que la reacción va
muy muy rápido pero como calculamos la
pendiente de esta línea curva bueno
necesitamos graficar la inversa de la
concentración contra el tiempo así
obtenemos una línea recta que se
relaciona con acá ahora veamos el caso
en el que necesitamos conocer el orden
total de la reacción como les
y si tenemos más de un reactivo puede
que cada uno obtenga un orden diferente
entonces primero analicemos los datos si
observamos las concentraciones de a
podemos ver que en los primeros dos
experimentos se mantiene constante pero
veamos qué pasó con b bueno podemos ver
que aumentó la concentración de b pero
la velocidad no cambió por lo tanto
sabemos que b participa en una reacción
de orden 0 y ahora analicemos el caso en
el que b es igual miren aquí y aquí no
cambia y si analizamos a podemos ver que
se duplica la concentración de a del
experimento 1 al 3 y si analizamos la
velocidad podemos ver que se eleva al
cuadrado así que para este caso la
velocidad es igual acá por la
concentración de a al cuadrado es de
segundo orden por b que ya dijimos que
es de orden 0 y como esto es igual a 1
podemos conocer el orden total de la
reacción y bueno ahora me gustaría darle
un problema pueden descubrir cuál es el
orden total de esta reacción pausa en el
vídeo inténtenlo y escriban su respuesta
en la descripción
ahora supongamos que tenemos todos estos
datos y no queremos analizar los puntos
solo queremos conocer el orden de la
reacción rápidamente hay una forma muy
fácil de hacer esto
miren supongamos que esta es la
concentración de nuestro reactivo y
simplemente podemos graficar la
concentración contra el tiempo es decir
todos estos datos van en el eje x y
estos en el eje y y después podemos
graficar el logaritmo natural de la
concentración contra el tiempo y
finalmente gráfica mos la inversa de la
concentración contra el tiempo y donde
obtengamos una línea recta sabremos cuál
es el orden de la reacción ya sea orden
cero primer orden o segundo orden un
ejemplo de esto en el laboratorio de
química es la descomposición del cristal
violeta también conocido como violeta de
genciana al principio es morado pero
cuando lo mezclamos con hidróxido
obtenemos una solución transparente y lo
que podemos hacer es usar un
espectrofotómetro
un espectrofotómetro me de la absorban
cya es decir la cantidad de luz que es
absorbida por un compuesto y podemos
graficar la absorban cya contra el
tiempo después el logaritmo natural de
la absorban cya contra el tiempo y
después la inversa de la absorban cya
contra el tiempo
la absorban cya en realidad nos dice que
tanto cristal violeta hay presente entre
más tengamos más luz es absorbida y así
podemos saber cuál de estas gráficas
genera una línea recta y así podremos
conocer el valor de acá entonces lo
aprendieron aprendieron a analizar los
datos de la concentración contra el
tiempo para determinar la ley de
velocidad para una reacción de orden
cero primer y segundo orden espero que
les sirva